[Music]
[Music]
welcome to wisdom for life where we sit
through philosophy to find practical
advice you can use in your everyday life
hi i'm dan hayes and i'm joined with my
co-host dr greg sadler and today we're
talking about
am i the jerk hole now if that sounds
like a funny word to you we're actually
making it up because we can't say the
the real word on the air
but you know it's the thing that
everybody's got sort of like opinions if
you know that that phrase and there is a
reddit forum that i don't it's drawn a
lot of attention over the years and it's
incredibly
helpful from a moral philosophy
perspective because people go on it and
they ask the question am i a jerk or as
we're going to say here the jerkle it's
a-i-t-a
and
a while back dan and i did an episode
devoted to
looking through these and saying can
these be useful exercises or useful
cases for thinking about ethical life
and decision making and all the stuff
that goes into personal development and
the answer is yes
they're also pretty entertaining i think
some of them and uh so we're not going
to spend too much time rehashing what we
talked about back in that episode and we
might do more of these in the future
because they're they're so much fun
to unpack instead we've got a whole
bunch of cases
lined up that dan and i are going to go
through and examine and analyze and talk
about you know is somebody the jerk is
somebody else the jerk is everybody how
do they put it on the the forum
everybody's a jerk
um
um
everyone sucks here oh okay yeah and
then and then there's so
there's the possibility that nobody's
bad right
right so we're gonna do a little bit of
decision making and judgment about them
and you can you know participate in this
as well you can think
about them as we're reading it aloud
what would you
say about these you know we're always
happy to get listener comments um about
the show
so before we launch into these dan
anything you think we need to
hit on but just to reiterate like
a large part of philosophy is ethics and
there are
many different schools of ethics and
we've talked about a lot of them in the
past it's kind of like one of our go-to
uh topics of conversation but uh we can
talk about theory all we want but unless
you're actually starting to put these
things into practice um you're not going
to really like find those like edge
cases where you're like making you feel
uncomfortable and i
the whole point of this ex exercise is
that we have the ability to look at
actual real world experiences on and uh
apply our moral theories to them um
and see how these kind of make the are
still as well as make other people feel
that we're actually like utilizing this
ethical muscle that's actually a great
set of points you know
one of the
psychologists who
is is uh probably most associated
with the notion of moral development and
moral development theory is lawrence
kohlberg
and he's got this you know these stages
like stage one stage two stage three and
you move from a pre-conventional sort of
just you know response to stimulus
punishment and and reward all the way up
through like you know looking for social
approval or you know buying into things
like a social contract or ultimately um
you know values that can be shared
universally but one of the things that
he stresses is that we we learn how to
progress from one stage to another not
by being given like a handbook or just a
pad on the head we we actually develop
through conflict through
finding out that we're wrong about
things and then readjusting often not
you know happily but
but um you know
and so i think these these cases can be
really helpful and we should you know
the ones that we have picked out because
we went through um
you know the many thousands that are
available on the forum they're they're
adding you know maybe i don't know
hundreds a week
we we wanted to pick those that are
kind of difficult that don't have an
easy oh it's it's this way or it's this
way kind of solution
and that's so that we can really sink
our teeth into them and maybe learn
something in the process
right hey so there's a something i
wanted to have us consider before we
jump in and i think this is a really
interesting
issue so there's this quip from jonathan
tropper the book of joe
and i don't know that i
completely agree with it he lists it as
descartes
jerk hole axiom i think therefore i'm
not one and so what he says is the fact
that i suspect that i'm a jerk hole
means that i probably am not
because a real jerk hole doesn't think
that he's a jerk hole does he thereby
therefore by realizing that i am a
jericho i am in fact negating that very
realization am i not
so given that formulation what do you
what do you what's your initial reaction
to that do you buy it
i feel it's a false dichotomy okay uh
so i guess
uh at least for one's own
uh personal morality um i guess you you
start to realize when you're you're
interacting with other people if your
your morals are actually resulting in
the the beneficial encounters that you
want with other people
um
and
so you either have uh you've got a set
of axioms and people are really unhappy
about them and you are a jerk hole um
and you don't even realize you're like
oh well those people are just jerks yeah
on not not knowing that every the fact
that everyone is a jerk is means that
you're a jerk and they're all responding
to you in that kind
there are those people who have realized
that like as this particular axiom goes
um and that they stop doing these things
and then i think there's definitely a
place in between a liminal space where
you start to learn these things but
you're still doing jerky things and so
you're still the jerkle and you're kind
of making progress away from being a
jerk right
right yeah and you could be like cool in
one way
and also a jerk in another way right at
the same time
so maybe there's there's a number of
ways to get out of this as i think
you're right it is a false dichotomy
i kind of think that there are some
people
who suspect that they're jerks
and actually are jerks
but don't completely understand maybe
because they they haven't been given
enough tools
how their how and why they're jerks
you know so maybe just suspecting that
you're a jerk doesn't get you off the
hook
or once again you could uh totally
embrace being the jerk because you
think that what you're doing gets you
what you consider to be good and you can
say yeah oh yeah i'm solely a jerk um
but against results
and and that's what they consider the
good in this case yeah you know it also
i think there's some people who are
pretty cynical and they think
everybody's a jerk why shouldn't i be a
jerk right there they're laboring under
a certain kind of misanthropy
or paranoia about other human beings and
so that justifies for them that jerkish
behavior
you know i'm also reminded before we
jump into the cases of something that
i've seen as a professor
over you know the last 20 years i i have
colleagues who complain about students
and you know the students they don't
listen in class and they're not engaging
with the material and all that and then
i've observed their classes and they
behave in jerkish ways towards their
students you know they act like oh we're
reading plato and and plato's so much
beyond all of you rum dums you know who
aren't philosophy majors you know you
business majors or fashion majors or
communication majors and then they're
really surprised that the students don't
like them and don't spend a lot of time
reading the text that they've just
talked up you know the difficulty and
inaccessibility of right and and then
the students you know it's sort of like
a feedback loop right the students are
unenthusiastic or hostile and then they
they you know come back at the students
and they're
they talk down to them or they're you
know arbitrarily picking on one student
or another and it makes for a really bad
classroom dynamic and then you know they
don't realize that they're they're
essentially the catalyst causing that
because you can take the same set of
students and a different instructor
and a different instructor who is like
oh you know this is difficult stuff but
we're going to work our way through it
and i think this is really valuable i
hope you find it's valuable here's some
resources to help you oh you've made a
mistake you're not a dummy this is a
common mistake that students make in
doing this let's walk our way through it
and the students respond usually
positively to that
and then it creates a positive feedback
loop i've seen a lot of my peers um
just you know blame the students for
everything and it's like you were saying
right if everybody else around you is
the jerk hole no it's probably not them
it's probably you
right
yeah uh and i guess the only other like
quadrant
probably not an exhaustive list is
when you have people from
really different backgrounds and there
are certain expectations
um
and and one person coming from a totally
different paradigm on
things that he's acting in a very
morally expected way yeah and they're
not for example i had a friend
um
who was an engineer from india um
and he uh i was having some people we
went out to a bar for a birthday okay on
for his is my birthday and on usually at
least in the united states kind of the
ideas
the birthday person usually drinks for
free or at least gets at least one
uh free drink yeah uh you know at the
beginning of night you know on uh
apparently
his axiom was that the birthday person
buys the others drinks
and so i was expecting him to pay for my
drink and he was expecting me to pay for
his drink and it's just like what's
going on so the bill comes and both of
you are looking at each other like okay
come on exactly yeah right
i've heard that for for other countries
as well um i don't know if it's actually
true or not but i had a german friend
who told me that that was the case in
germany and so like you avoid going out
on your birthday because you don't want
to pay for things
uh but i i think that's actually a great
point too there are a lot of ways in
which um
what would we call them cultural
differences of cultural norms yeah uh
could could lead to
significant
misunderstandings of people being jerks
and then because we get we typically get
hostile or angry towards jerks or
withdraw from them
there's a good chance for other people
to see us as being jerks
as a response right
right
oh yes it comes down to that uh
communication breakdown
it's always the same you know and in the
cases that we've got here i think that
is the problem for quite a few of them
is a lack of effective communication
things are being communicated but
they're not the messages that the other
person actually wants to hear
right so maybe let's
jump right into it or let's do case
number one yeah case number one okay
um am i the jerk hole for telling the
truth and exposing a web of lies my wife
has spun
ooh so my wife has been lying a lot
lately she is obviously conscious of
people's feelings and she uses white
lies to shift the blame onto others to
lessen the blow of a situation always to
her benefit she will find herself in
situations where she wants to back out a
weekend plans with her friends or
explain why she did something seemingly
rude etc but she always blames me my
husband doesn't want me to leave this
weekend sorry he's being such a jerk or
i only
screenshotted this conversation we had
because my husband told me he wanted to
see it
sure i can handle someone confronting me
about that stuff far better than she can
she has high anxiety when it comes to
confrontation but i'm really sick of
being her scapegoat and letting people
think i'm a selfish jerk
i was watching our kids this weekend
while my wife hosted a bachelorette trip
for her friends at my wife's aunt's lake
house last night my wife calls me and
says i can come over with the kids
rather than wait till early this morning
like planned i get to the lake house and
the girls are still out at a bar
somewhere so i let myself in and put the
kids to bed
my wife's aunt texts her after seeing me
on her security cam and tells her she is
upset that i was there that's weird to
me because she and i get along very well
and i'm even renting a house from her
she has
really high anxiety but she manages it
really well most of the time she then
texts me this morning and begins yelling
at me about how i got no right to invite
myself over and that i'm a bad father
naturally i'm shocked and asked her what
she meant
turns out my wife texted her saying she
didn't know i was coming over and that
i'm an incompetent father and she had to
help me because i don't know how to
watch our kids i told her that was not
true and that my wife invited me to come
because she knows it was closer to my
work and i could sleep in rather than
get up early to bring the kids
i of course confronted my wife about why
she would lie about me and say things
like that about me she then goes and
gets mad and says that she was going
doing damage control in the situation
and that it was far better for aunt is
mad at me than her so now we're fighting
because i of course don't appreciate
being put in that situation but my wife
thinks it was a necessary sacrifice to
keep her aunt happy with her
so tldr wife told her on to lie to save
aunt confronted me i told the truth wife
is now mad at me what do you think greg
well this
this is an interesting one and there's a
lot to unpack here i mean i at first
i don't think that the person the guy is
the jerk at all i think clearly the wife
is is a jerk in this case
and the interesting question is well how
and why you know and
i think it's telling that this is not
just like one
situation that's a completely
out of the blue one-off sort of thing
but it but it sounds like this is part
of a
dynamic and that it may have like hit
the last straw
you know the straw that broke the
camel's back sort of sort of thing i
mean what's what's your view on this one
yeah i'm with you here as well that you
know the husband is not the jerk hole
here
and there there's
a history of bad actions in the past and
specifically um i see two major things
one is just kind of lying on in general
is usually not the go-to and if that is
your your regular modus operandi then
you know that that allows you to
easierly do
larger lives yeah
i think that there's something about
this though you know like so let's say
you are a couple and you're like oh man
it's the end of the week we're both
really tired we just want to like order
a pizza and watch a show rather than go
to this uh event that we're signed up
for and people are expecting us and now
you talk about it right and you're like
okay both of us are cool with this we're
gonna we're gonna come up with some and
it's it's a lie
we're gonna come up with some
justification we'll say that uh one of
us um fell down and hit their head
just make up something right and uh you
know then then
you know we obviously can't go
there's
there's a i don't know what would we
call it there's there's like consent
there there's
agreement there's there's a working
something out together whereas let's say
it's you and me right and we we say that
we're gonna um go on and do a radio show
and then instead of uh i i flake out and
instead of um
telling the station manager that i
flaked out i just shift the blame to you
completely and you don't even know that
i'm shifting the blame to you that
sounds more like this situation right so
it's not just the lying it's
i this sounds a little weird but it's
the lying without having gotten somebody
else to co-sign it or to consent to it
right
um
because
the whole idea of like if you're in a
marriage this is a partnership yeah is
it not and that you're like there are
certain things especially if you kind of
like know what your partner would do in
a certain situation yeah um you might be
able to make certain decisions for them
um
but uh it seems that he's
not
happy about the state of the situation
and yeah the whole idea of making these
excuses um and shifting the blame
without his permission that he can do
that it's like it's one thing to
like
go to a party and you you say like okay
to your your partner okay on what when i
start sneezing that is the uh
of the sign that we need to get out of
this party so
i'm just i'm done with it yeah yeah yeah
politely excuse ourselves um but like
there needs to be
communication of what is an acceptable
uh sacrifice i guess you'll you'll make
for that particular relationship and
obviously one person is is making this a
decision without their partner's consent
that's
not conducive for the long-term
relationship do you think it matters in
a case like this like how
damaging the lies are i mean some of the
things like saying that somebody's an
incompetent father that's that's pretty
heavy stuff right that's harsh yeah yeah
uh yeah i guess
yeah it's one thing to like
oh you know he was he was feeling under
the weather today or something yeah but
uh like
that's a pretty big value judgment that
you just throw out there as a way to
save face
um
you know i guess i don't
particularly
uh value reputation all that much but
i'm there are some there's some aspects
that could kind of get you in trouble if
you're if you're throwing around
accusations of being a bad parent you
know maybe social services gets called
or right you know there are definitely
uh
just preferred things that are going to
happen later yeah if that that is a
known expectation about you
what about the anxiety thing um
one could make the case that okay
uh
his wife his his sister-in-law they both
suffer from anxiety maybe that gets them
off the hook for
their particular behavior and mostly the
wife in this case right
the wife is clearly anxious about how
people view her she doesn't want to be
the one who's
viewed as the
baddie right um
i guess
as far as i can tell from this
uh that that confrontation is the the
major trigger for her anxiety
um
but just because you have a
a medical condition
isn't an excuse for you
doing bad things yeah and
what i see here is her
executing bad things by telling these
lies and especially
on
calling him a bad husband or a bad
father on in order to to save her that
discomfort i know that anxiety can be
really
crippling
um but
you need to find a better way to deal
with that than also causing harm
you know it's interesting now that i
think about it so
if she's
using this mode of behavior
which is you know borderline abusive to
deal with her anxiety toward that that's
felt towards other people and what they
think of her
you would think that it would also
it would be counterproductive in some
way because it would lead to
at least some anxiety about how
her spouse
feels
whether he's gonna like stay with her
how he views her you know it's it's sort
of like um
i don't know
again i go back to like students
students who often say oh i can't get
these assignments done because of my
anxiety but then they're very worried
about how you
um
how you look at them as well as a
instructor you know maybe some responses
to anxiety
are
they're rational in a certain level but
they're also irrational on a higher
level
you know
yeah um like
i know i i've got a little anxiety
myself and but i do have certain coping
mechanisms to to deal with it i know
it's it feels really uncomfortable yeah
on it there's a very strong
physiological response to it um but
uh
i guess in my case i don't see anywhere
where i'm going to
uh start using that excuse to hurt other
people yeah i mean do you think that
there's a duty if you're in a a close
relationship so it could be like a
marriage it could be like
a long-term partnership it could be a
close friendship that if you are
and we'll broaden it from anxiety to
other things if you're if you're
suffering from something that causes you
to
every once in a while
um go off course and do something that's
that's harmful to the other person do
you have a duty to like get that under
wraps in some way you know to start
going to
therapy or finding as you said coping
mechanisms to to not necessarily to
completely root it out but at least you
know minimize
what happens
i would say yes as well as um when you
do it you should realize that these
things
like
in retrospect you should see that these
things aren't oh
good actions and so if you're you're
asserting that this is a good thing that
you've done this
um i guess i would have a problem with
that assessment that's an interesting
still a bad thing and and her idea that
this is a a good thing that
this absolves her of any guilt for this
that's a problem yeah yeah there's a
definitely a problem okay she's not
working towards
bettering or even acknowledging that
there's anything wrong here yeah
do you think that um the fact that
there's kids um raises the stakes
because the kids are observing this
interaction between mom and dad
um
hmm
i mean in a way differently than say
like pets would pets pets don't care if
yeah i mean you can yell at each other
right right like that but they're not
picking up bad character traits as being
normal you know i i guess if
if that's within your shadow chits then
i'd say as yeah i'm not quite sure if
that is actually the the truth in this
particular example but yeah that's
definitely not something that one would
want to model a relationship around okay
let's go on to the next one the next
one's a bit shorter and
this one's uh i'll be i'm curious to see
what you make of this one
am i the jerk for making the best of my
work trips
um
am i the jerk hole for taking advantage
of work trips to ride my bike in new
places over the last six months i've
started to having to travel a fair
amount for work
during the trips i do my best to ensure
that it's as short a trip as possible
for example if possible i'll fly in on a
monday afternoon work tuesday then fly
out first thing wednesday morning
recently i've made it a habit of
bringing my road bike on these trips the
bike box can be checked for free before
my trip i'll find some local route that
i want to do i'll adjust my schedule to
get my ride in often starting at 5 a.m
this has been irritating my wife she
thinks that i'm going on many vacations
because i'm bringing my road bike i've
made the argument that i'm not adding
any time to my work trips as i'm not
staying over additional days to do these
rides
this isn't this is an interesting one
and at first my temptation was to say no
he's totally not being the jerk hole at
all um
it's an overreaction but then as i
thought about it more i thought well
maybe there's maybe there's something to
this what's what's your view dan
yeah for the for the action itself
it's not a bad action what i would call
the action itself not a jerkle but
um yeah i felt like there is something
more to this and i don't think it's the
the surface reason but it's more along
the lines of i feel how uh the wife can
feel left out in one of these
experiences that her husband's going on
and doing all these fun things
out of town without her um and once
again you know you're
uh you're married you're in a
partnership and she's feeling like oh
he's getting all these vacations in
without me yeah um why don't i get a
vacation
and uh why is all like if you're not
prioritizing that relationship and
i feel like there there's
a
place there where where
a
a sliver is been entered in this might
be one of the cases
where we don't actually have enough
information to make a really great
decision about it because we do want to
know why so he's saying she thinks i'm
going on many vacations why should that
necessarily
bother her like if i can tell you that
if my wife wanted to go
on many vacations while she was
going to a conference or something like
that i'd be totally cool with it
in fact i'd probably encourage it so
why
does she feel like he's doing something
without her and she's missing out on it
or maybe
it's something that they should be doing
together or if she's not having fun he
shouldn't be having fun we don't
actually know from
from this um
this little vignette do we
right
yes i have to like
i said the action itself as as described
on
is is not a bad action internet it
actually strikes me as a positive action
he's
doing something thoughtful it's healthy
for him it's you know i mean pick
imagine if it was instead
so
when i have this layover i try to find
the you know closest strip joint that
i'm gonna like sit around in and blow
money and drink drink liquor and look at
other other you know people and you know
this isn't that this is a guy getting on
his bike at five in the morning
i mean not the sort of thing i'd want to
do anyway but
um you know i could see like going
hiking or going to a museum those things
strike me as like well you're improving
your life you're doing something
productive um
as well as he gets to do something that
would if you pursues it outside would it
cost them as a married couple money
right yeah benefit there yeah yeah he's
pursuing his goals
um
but yeah once again there's there's
definitely something else here
on
that
isn't
left unknown so maybe the lesson that we
can take from this that i i had no idea
we were going to learn
is oftentimes when we get these
scenarios we really have to have more
information and we should exercise a
certain restraint in
making judgments
and puzzlement may be where we
wind up rather than a clear judgment
right
so uh shall we move to yeah that's why
all right
so
am i the jerk for eating someone else's
chipotle order
so
like manna from heaven but this happened
a year ago i still feel weird about it
so one day in the afternoon i was
starving i was watching some tv when
someone knocked on the door when i
opened the door there was a chipotle
delivery man outside holding a delivery
without a second thought i took it
thinking my parents probably ordered it
for me as soon as i closed the door i
rushed to the table and ate it super
quickly i was very hungry
the delivery was very good and once i
had finished eating it i went back to
watching tv
a half hour later i heard a knock on the
door when i opened the door i saw a
regular dude who asked me if the
chipotle package might have come by here
by accident immediately i was horrified
he knew it too from my eyes and said
you hate it didn't you
he didn't look mad just empty feeling
super bad i said yes and offered to even
pay for what i ate instead he just said
it was fine and left
am i the jerk for eating someone else's
chipotle order
by accident
i don't know if accident is is wholly
warranted here
okay why not he
he made an assumption
on and we know what uh happens when you
make an assumption right you make a jerk
out of you and me um
and
so
at least there is like
a little bit of a
silver lining to this
rain cloud that he didn't own up to it
immediately and he offered restitution
um but he really should have actually
checked if someone was ordering him and
not just assume that food coming to his
house was going to be his
yeah i'm a little bit intrigued by this
why is he so torn up about it
a year later you know
it seems to have really stuck with him
and i mean if it had really stuck with
him
you know the guys in his apartment
building you would have thought he could
have like
ordered chipotle for that guy and sent
it over you know mate if he really
wanted to to make restitution it seems
like an easy
easy way to do so rather than to just
mull it over and feel bad
for a year now that doesn't make you a
jerk that just makes you
i don't know poorly adjusted or
you know uh counterproductive when it
comes to your own personal development
maybe
um it strikes me as a pretty kind person
go ahead absolution like he offered to
pay or buy
uh some more chipotle for him but the
guy denied that and so maybe he was
looking for
um hey i can do this so we can
we can go back to an equal point but now
he just has to live with the fact that
he did something that he doesn't
think is good and he sees his neighbor
every once in a while and every time he
sees him he's like gosh
i really should have bought him some
chipotle
why he doesn't just do it as like a
random act
exactly yeah
i mean and it's a pretty trivial thing
it's sort of like taking somebody's
parking space for an hour or
um
i mean opening somebody's mail is
actually you know a federal offense i
think right although you could say well
i did i didn't know it was yours um well
it's not technically the mail
oh is it it's not the like you get a
letter chipotle delivery oh no i'm
saying
analogies to this right oh okay so
it seems like
you know fairly trivial stuff like
imagine you open you open mail for
yourself
thinking that it's yours and it's the
neighbors and it's actually just junk
mail that you're gonna throw out anyway
and they would probably throw out too
you know this seems to be kind of uh
like on that level um
it's almost like or like not holding the
door for somebody you're worried about
not holding the door for somebody
a year later
you know
yeah that seems a little weird to me i
actually have that issue
um i'm holding halfway regularly
no about uh opening other people's mail
because my next door neighbor on my
address ensign nine his address ends in
a seven oh okay and
his first name and my first name are the
same are you serious
no
sorry yes i'm very serious uh uh so
every once in a while i'm like i'm going
through the mail and you're just like oh
let's it says
dan dan dan yeah yeah oh
why do i have something from disney
okay yeah
well so so i think this one's pretty
straightforward is he a jerk
i don't think so
what do you what do you say
he's a little bit of a jerk okay i feel
like him just assuming that food that
arrives at his door is absolutely his
especially after i don't know if you've
like used any of the
the mobile apps for ordering food oh
we've had people sometimes just walk off
with our food
right
um
but
there's a myriad of problems that i
found with these apps yeah and
and there's always it's better to double
check
that's true yeah yeah
so maybe maybe he had he he had a duty
of due diligence or something like that
i i kind of like this idea of adding the
category
um not like a complete jerk hole but
kind of a jerk hole you know
yeah
more of like what was it the difference
between like what murder and
manslaughter oh right one has to have
like premeditation
and forethought
uh whereas the other one's just like oh
yeah yeah screwed up real bad yeah
yeah that that i mean those are much
more serious than this but oh yes but
but there's definitely that on
either
omission or
commission acts of omission or
commission that you're you're
uh
or you're doing something
uh specifically because you intend to
harm versus doing things
just because you weren't very good about
it
yeah there's i mean there's also like
negligent homicide that's in there kind
of in that spectrum
um where you should have thought
something through but didn't
yeah well let's look at the next one
this this is one that is very close to
my heart as a cat lover uh am i the jerk
hole for refusing to give up my cat even
though my fiance is allergic
me and my fiance moved in together in
2019 i've always been a pet person my
fiance has not and he finally agreed to
let me get a cat last year provided i'd
do all the work to take care of it i
agreed and happily feed the cat clean
the litter box take him to the vet etc
shortly after we got the cat my fiance
started having allergies nothing
life-threatening but he says he has
trouble trouble sleeping at night due to
a stuffy nose he takes medicine and
everything but still says sleep is still
hard he gets about seven to eight hours
of sleep almost every night which is how
much he slept before we got the cat but
he says he feels more well rested when
not sleeping in our apartment
i suggest that he go to the doctor to
look at other options to deal with the
allergies but he won't set up an
appointment the allergies don't bother
him at all during the day so i think he
just forgets about it i'm constantly
vacuuming washing the sheets not letting
the cat into our bedroom etc in order to
try and help but pet dander is next to
impossible to get rid of after a
particularly bad night of sleep my
fiance asked me to re-home the cat
i refuse because i think it's wrong to
give up an animal unless absolutely
necessary and we both made a commitment
when we adopted the cat also i think my
fiance's allergies are something he can
live with since he usually gets enough
sleep and i feel like he hasn't tried
every option to deal with it better
the cat is also a rescue and has been
abandoned before as a result he is very
attached to me and follows me everywhere
i would feel absolutely terrible giving
him up because i know he wouldn't do
well with the adjustment
my fiance is upset because he feels like
i'm choosing the cat over him i hate
that he's not sleeping as well as he
could and i really want him to be as
comfortable as possible in his own home
but at the same time i can't imagine
giving up the cat am i the jerk hole
this one strikes me as a genuine moral
dilemma although i i do have feelings
about who the jerk is in this case
what's your take
so let's talk about the moral dilemma
first so we've got two different
competing
uh goods i guess seemingly competing i
think is part of the problem yeah right
and so you've got on either the
well-being of one's relationship
um or
the the well-being of this pet that you
have made a commitment to
take care of yeah
and so
i know i guess how do you see those two
intermingling i think the well-being of
the relationship part is also got the
weight of you know the well-being of of
the fiance right so there's two things
on that side
and you can say that one signifies the
other so her
her taking as seriously as her fiance
does his capacity to get sleep is for
him
signifying whether he
whether she
cares as much about the relationship
as as he does and he he's really the one
who's who's forcing the moral dilemma
and saying
you know it's either this or that right
and then she's the one who's feeling the
moral dilemma
um
i kind of think it's not really a moral
dilemma it's a it's a seeming moral
dilemma one that's being imposed by the
fiance and i think the key right here is
that she says
i suggest that he go to the doctor to
look at other options but he won't make
an appointment right so that that right
there is telling to me
um
there there there are two
actions that are happening here we've
got the
um
the the
woman who
um is has the cat and
um seems to be doing everything she
possibly can yeah um in order to
actually yeah um make sure that both the
relationship as well as the cat are
happy
um and and there's a disconnect or a
discontinuity between
with the amount of effort that she's
going in to do this as the fiancee is
going into this so yeah absolutely what
you said the whole um
decided not to go to the allergist
um
and
and thus he's he's not doing enough work
to actually try to resolve this without
going to basically the nuclear option
here yeah yeah that's a good point
um
i mean
i know people who have
allergies in in
to pets that are in their homes and
you know find ways to to live with it um
and that they do that in part because
they they value either the person who's
attached to the pet or they value the
pet themself
so
i mean it seems like the the boyfriend
or the fiance rather is not i mean she
says he's not really a pet person
so
maybe he's he's just not into the
maybe he doesn't understand the value of
the pet it also i mean
if if the cat wasn't a rescue who's been
abandoned before and very attached
um
and that she she you know thinks that he
wouldn't do well with the adjustment i
think it would be an easier case they
could consider
um
having somebody else adopt the cat but
i don't know about this one
you know as well as just the whole idea
of
once you enter into
that agreement to
take care of an animal that is not
something one should enter into lightly
uh just because
he's uh
might have not realized like
the full weight of this thing but like
yeah to
uh remove yourself from that argument um
or that that
agreement uh is uh
not what you would call like
um excellent
of a pet owner it reminds me so when i
was in graduate school down in
carbondale illinois i i lived in a
trailer park for about four years
because it was you know super cheap
and there were a lot of
other students either undergraduates or
graduate students who who lived in
trailer parks as well same reason it was
super cheap and and
many of them would adopt
puppies or kittens
and then it was mostly the
undergraduates they they were typically
like from the chicagoland area and
they'd gone down to southern illinois
because
it was you know cheap in-state tuition
and it was a place that they could go to
and it was known for being a party
school so i think that was an attraction
to quite a few students they also had
some some programs that were
particularly good
but quite a few of these students
especially with kittens would adopt a
kitten and then have it with them and
then when they moved home they just left
it in the trailer park to go wander
around look for food on its own
i actually ended up adopting uh one of
them myself
who was you know very tame and and my my
cats actually got along with and uh he
was clearly somebody's pet who'd just
been abandoned and there were many of
these and you could see it like
happening
every end of the spring semester there
would suddenly be all these these
not pharaoh but abandoned um
adult animals
wandering around mostly mostly cats
and i think that that showed a real lack
of maturity
on their part and made you know
effectively makes them the
the uh jerk holes in cases like that now
the the
the um
[Music]
fiance i don't know if he's
maybe maybe we need that classification
he's kind of a jerk hole in this case
you know i don't think she is at all i
think she's she's making a real bona
fide effort to uh
make the situation the situation yeah
yeah
but
i can't even imagine
uh
just abandoning one of my pets
i've had cats and dogs my entire
most my life and
oh man
i couldn't
yeah no that i don't even want to think
about it i will i will tell you
something and and some of the listeners
might think oh wow this guy's really a
softy because of it but um i you know
when i was living in the trailer park i
had my cats and they were i would let
them outside but i would keep them on
like long clothesline leashes because i
didn't want them wandering around
everywhere in the trailer park because
it was kind of dangerous
for animals and every once in a while my
my cat whose name was little boy and he
was he was gigantic he grew to be about
25 pounds
um
and he um he would get get loose he was
very strong and he he wanted to like
check things out so he'd get loose and i
would have to like walk up and down the
rows calling for him and then he'd you
know like trot out and he'd be happy and
he
but i'd be worried sometimes that like
what if he got lost and he was missing
me and doesn't know where he is and
nobody's taking care of him
you know and uh that really got to me
that that
that sense and i think some people have
the opposite of that they're like screw
it i you know they're out of my hair you
know but that's that's at antipodes how
i feel from about about the animals that
i've committed to
right i've i've got i've had
and still do a very strong emotional
attachment to
my cat or my pets specifically my cats i
was yeah family used to call me when i
was younger uh dan the cat man
you know i will say and leading into our
next one which is about spy yes so i've
had a lot of different kinds of pets
i've had dogs i've had cats i've had
guinea pigs
um i've actually had pet spiders in kind
of a way similar to the case that is
going to be talked about here not like
tarantulas but like just go out and you
know get a crab spider and put it in a
jar and keep feeding it
i didn't feel the kind of
closeness and
worry about it with
you know arthropods as i as i did
mammals
um
and i think maybe that's reflective of
something i think if i were to get like
a snake i don't think i would get as
attached to it as as i did cats or you
know fish i i don't think i would get it
as attached to them
um so
this last one here is uh my daughter is
16 and my son is 14.
my son and my husband are both
arachnophobes and whilst my husband is
okay with dealing with spiders my son
absolutely cannot
be in the same house as a spider every
time he sees a spider he needs someone
to kill it or he'll do it himself if
it's slow then he asks us to get pet
control to hopefully kill any eggs or
any other spiders my daughter has always
loved animals and more specifically
spiders she has always wanted a pet
tarantula but we've always said no way
the thing is scary and can bite no not
to mention the costs we already have two
dogs and a cat recently my daughter had
been has been finding random spiders and
catching them and bringing them into the
home i know about this and my husband
said listen as long as i never have to
go into your room i'm fine with it
however my son did not know about this
because he never goes into his sister's
room even though he's right across the
hall from each other
there were a lot of spiders and she kept
them in plastic containers she had to
feed them by opening the lid one day my
son was in his room and a spider from
his sister's room got in he ran out and
into his sister's room and found two
medium-sized spiders on the wall he tear
he was terrified and ran out of the
house and texted me
saying he's going to a friend's house
he's been staying there for two days
they're close family friends so it's
okay
but he has refused to come home saints
infested with spiders my son has
in
my son was in complete anxiety couldn't
come home without the spiders gone i put
my foot down and told my daughter that
we're going to get rid of every single
spider she was in hysterics but to me
spiders are simply not worth my son
being in constant anxiety in his own
home she's screaming
favoritism and saying that we favor him
because he's a boy she also said that
it's his mental issue he
so he should just deal with it and that
is her room and her life and she can do
what she wants
so
so
i
think that um
in this case
i don't think the mom is being a jerk
i i think
and i think that um there probably is
favoritism being shown
but that's not enough to make you a jerk
in this case given the level of anxiety
that's that's being displayed here
um and you know it's i think there is a
difference in the animals it's different
like if somebody had um like a cat
phobia and you had a cat in your room i
don't you know and you're strongly
attached to it i don't know about that
one you know or a ferret or
some other mammal or maybe even certain
birds
but spiders i mean i like spiders i used
to i used to um
you know deliberately
feed trapdoor spiders crickets to watch
them and that sucks for the crickets
right but you know circle of life and
all that and i used to uh catch you know
crab spiders and have them in my room
and let them crawl on me and i i have a
half brother who's had tarantulas and
you know tarantulas are actually you
know kind of kind of cool and they don't
really they're not they're probably not
going to bite you you know um
but i don't know i i think that in a
case like this
um if it was if it was like adult
roommates maybe i would actually say the
adult roommate needs to get over his
anxiety but you know a kid
who's arachnophobic whose sister has
filled up her room of spiders
what do you think you know
almost seems like a nightmare um yeah
yeah it doesn't seem well thought out
that's for sure right so i guess
my first idea is like as a parent one
has a duty to try and create a safe and
healthy place for all of their children
okay yeah uh
uh
other compromises can be made for
her daughter and so she can find like
potentially oh yeah put them out of the
house put them in a shed outside
someplace
um
you know they're they're wild creatures
anyways they know how to get through the
the winters and whatnot yeah that's
actually a great idea
or um you know potentially there are
local nature centers where she can
help like i know like i grew up with
there's a place here in milwaukee called
the urban ecology center that has a
wide menagerie of different like
local creatures that they keep as part
of their their teaching tools i assume
there's at least a couple spiders there
as well i can't remember exactly but
like there are other outlets for
these things maybe she can have maybe
she has a friend that's
also similarly interested in spiders and
and no one that their house has a
problem with that there are there are
other potential options here yeah
this one also strikes me re-reading it
as a little bit fishy right if if the
sun is arachnophobic
and she says um that her daughters
always loved animals
why more specifically spiders i mean
is it is there something like
sibling rivalry going on there maybe
behind the scenes you know like i i'm
gonna stick it to
uh
my brother who i know is bothered by
this sort of thing
i also thought it was weird too that she
so she screams favoritism i think there
is favoritism there and saying we favor
him because he's a boy she also said
it's his mental issues now the mental
issues i think she's she's right about
that right and and that is something
that it's kind of unfair to her but they
got to deal with it but favoring him
because he's a boy
i don't get that in this one do you
uh without any extra context
uh there's nothing in here that
specifically counts that
but yeah i was thinking about like what
what are the things that one needs or
like
what what obligations do you have to
your
to your family like in order to actually
we would talk about like relationships
earlier it's like what what are the
things that are required for those
and you know i think there are
definitely other things you can say like
for a family especially
like the nuclear family unit what what
are the
the places where one gives in in order
to maintain the health and happiness of
all the people within that family
that's that's a good point um and we
could think of all sorts of analogous
situations that don't involve pets or
necessarily even phobias but could be
like you know so like she's saying
um something that kids typically do it's
her room and her life and she can do
what she wants so you know like when we
were kids um we played our music you
know arguably way too loud and my mom
didn't really like that
and now looking back on it as an adult i
think we were really jerks me and my
sister you know playing heavy metal
whenever we wanted to we'd actually like
we lived out in in uh
the town of delafield at the time so you
know we lived in a subdivision but it
wasn't all that filled in and we would
like put our speakers in the windows you
know so not only are we like you know
the other neighborhood kids would come
over and we'd skateboard or play
basketball or whatever but it must have
really been awful for the neighbors you
know for the neighbor adults who weren't
into heavy metal
because we got these kids doing this
sort of thing you know and it's and it's
kind of uh thoughtless i mean they're
having a good time with it but
not every everybody else is so right
you know or
i get perturbed a little bit when people
come
i would just play music in their cars is
really loud yeah well now as an older
person i do too you know or when
motorcycles are driving by and they're
they're being really noisy i don't like
that either
i know i'm on the other side of the
fence right
like usually i don't have a problem with
someone's like driving by but if they
like drive on the street and then park
and then sit and listen to the music
it's really loud right right it's like
why just ah yeah so within any sort of
living arrangement i mean we could talk
about um college dorms we could talk
about neighborhoods we could talk about
anything you want
there's some things that if you insist
on doing you're you may you know it is
your place to do with what you want but
you are being a jerk to other people
here in the downtown uh if we have the
windows open quite often there is such a
strong pot smell because you know laws
aren't being enforced and people love to
smoke pot and it doesn't really bother
me too much because you know it smells
kind of hoppy like like a decent ipa but
it bothers my my wife you know who's a
little bit more sensitive to those those
sorts of things and if it bothers her
well then that bothers me
you know and you could say well
who cares you know it's just for a
moment it's uh
the wind is gonna blow differently it's
just somebody walking down the street
and you say well maybe they shouldn't be
a jerk like that you know
yeah or i guess this is one of the the
you know the main things that you people
have to deal with within
a society in general what at what point
do you stop looking at yourself as just
a pure individual and when you start
looking at yourself as a part of a group
and what is
the limital area between there what are
the you know
ethics are all about how one
inter-reacts and integrates with the
people around them and if you're not
doing that well
um that is a great point yeah
yeah
yeah and it might not even questions it
might not even be a group there might be
a difference that we have to unpack here
as we're getting close to the end of the
hour
maybe we'll do this in a different show
there's like being in a group and then
there's like living in a community where
you're actually not in a group with
these people you're not in the same
family you just happen to live
in the same neighborhood or use the same
streets you still have a kind of moral
obligation right to not be a
jerk to them
right
yeah
yeah well um i don't think we're going
to get through any more cases but we
will do more of these if people like
this i think they do
judging from the comments
so do you want to take us out with a
pithy quote
we leave you today with the words harlan
ellison
philosophy of life is that the meek
shall inherit
nothing but disbasement frustration and
ignoble deaths
[Music]
so
[Music]
you